Km d'Irpin devant l'unique route encore
tenue par l'armée ukrainienne
et qui va tout droit vers vers cette
cette ville qui fait encore aujourd'hui
l'objet d'intenses combats,
l'armée nous a interdit l'accès à
Irpin,
mais nous avons pu observer près de
ce check point un va et vient incessant
de
véhicules militaires et d'ambulances qui
évacuent
les derniers habitants de la ville.
Nous avons rencontré une de ces familles
qui venait à peine
de partir à d'Irpin écouter.
On ne peut plus on emmener dans le sous
sol
de l'église quand ils ont commencé à
frapper toutes les nuits.
C'est un massacre, un massacre et rien
d'autre.
Personne ne peut supporter ça.
Jean-Louis, jeune homme, avoue t il,
voulait prendre l'Ukraine.
Mais l'Ukraine veut être indépendante.
Il n'abandonne jamais, jamais.
Nous voulons vivre ukrainienne et nulle
part ailleurs sous.
Je viens juste de sortir ma mère
d'Irpin. Maintenant,
je vais la mettre à l'abri dans un lieu
sûr. Ensuite,
je reviendrai aider d'autres personnes
en tout
notre église avec 3000 habitants.
Il y a d'autres sur survivants.
Derrière moi se trouvent des habitants
de d'Irpin qui ont été évacués.
Aujourd'hui,
même la quasi totalité de cette ville de
110.000 habitants a fui.
Beaucoup n'ont pas eu cette chance et
sont morts dans les combats.
Nous avons pu voir les corps de deux de
ces civils qui ont été emmenés ici par
des volontaires ukrainiens.